with the shot clock now at eight
young sees it timers at five drives
tries to pull it back getting bumped by
maxie
young let's go of it oh
trey young with another triple
atlanta back within a point
[Music]
[Applause]
young goes for almost turning it over
because of the defense of tyrese maxey
to hitting a three as the shot clock is
about to expire
he's got 34 points five threes 11
assists
and the hawks are down one trying to
close out this series with the sixers
ben
simmons back on the floor because we're
inside two minutes now right
maxie almost oh a lot of lights just
went out here as they inbounded the ball
well the lights go out on philly i guess
that's the
big question and on the process as well
so all the all the hawk fans have their
flashlights now on their phones here
they're
they're taking in every second of this
the entire building reacted to that
okay trey young literally shot the
lights up
yeah that last basket well i thought
that maxie almost had a deflection there
but trey young with the quick hands
regained control of the ball
and then got off a good look
man this post season has had everything
it's like every game there's something
that's right especially in this series